If you to invest your money in another
country,
I'm sure Venezuela wouldn't even be on
the list.
Rice wells,
if you a government,
it does not agree with it.
China agrees to invest $20,
million dollars in Venezuela to help
offset effects of oil price slump.
But hold on just a second because this
is not only about China.
Have you ever heard of Goldman Sachs?
It's one of those banks that symbolizes
American capitalism at its purest.
Well,
they too saw a lot of business
opportunity as in Madeira.
Venezuela buys two point $8,000,000,000
worth of Venezuelan bonds and an uproar
begins.
Yes,
you heard that right.
While Venezuela is having one of the
worst economic catastrophes humanity has
ever witnessed,
they keep making deals with the world's
biggest investors.
This is why,
despite the scarcity,
the extreme poverty and the
hyperinflation,
Nicolas Maduro is buying state of the
art weapons do maintain an army that
almost nobody could attack.
And Amit,
that has over 1000 rockets that were
manufactured in Russia in October of
this year.
That's 2017.
Madeira met Vladimir Putin to buy
weapons.
Yes.
Meanwhile,
at Venezuela is also the biggest partner
that China has in the region they ever
received,
way more trainees money than any other
Latin American country.
All right,
so now you might be wondering,
well,
what's the point of all of this?
Well,
finance wise,
China is pretty blinds to ideology and
the same goes for those American banks.
The only goal is to make money,
but at first sight and in Venezuela it
doesn't exactly look like a great place
to do business.
How did Venezuela come to the attention
of so many investors?
I mean,
where is the deal here?
Well,
today we are going to answer all of
those questions,
but before we do,
let's take a look back at the history.
Okay,
so here's some advice.
If you ever wanted to become a dictator
in your country and repress your
opinions and torture,
you'll many political foes.
That is something you absolutely need,
and yes,
of course that is money.
Yeah,
normal citizens can die from starvation,
but your beliefs and your army cannot
miss a single payday.
This is the biggest problem for an
authoritarian leader like Nicolas
Maduro.
The Venezuelan presidents,
his biggest problem is if the army
decides to striking
against
following visual politic for a long
time,
you know that Venezuela has almost no
private company is say there's not much
money to be collected in taxes for the
oil exports are no longer profitable
since the oil prices went down in 2012.
In other words,
his only way to pay for this whole
repressive apparatus is by getting loans
on the international market.
Hold on just a second here because
things are not as easy as they seem.
Venezuela is a country with terrible
economic problems.
This means if you lend them money,
chances are you're never going to get it
back.
This is why we say the Venezuelan bonds
are a very high risk investments as
well,
but to countries do when investors don't
trust them.
Well,
they raised the interest rates and this
is why Venezuelan bonds have a yield of
over 10 and 12 percent while a German
bonds,
which is way more reliable.
It doesn't surpass zero point five
percent.
All right,
so what does all of this means?
Let's imagine we invest a thousand US
dollars in Venezuelan bonds to be paid
in 10 years with an interest of 10
percent.
Theoretically,
the Venezuelan government is expected to
give us back those thousand dollars that
we lead them,
but in the meantime you'll receive $100
every year as an interest payment.
Well,
yes,
I can probably guess what you're
thinking right now.
That sounds like a pretty great
business.
Well,
do you notice,
get excited just yet.
As we said before,
Venezuela has a pretty high chance of
default.
If the governments of Caracas,
the capital of Venezuela declares
bankruptcy and say two years,
we're going to have lost 80 percent of
our investments.
This is why despite the high interest
rates,
Nicolas Maduro has founded harder and
harder to sell his bombs.
Amds well,
this explains news like this.
Goldman Sachs,
it's Venezuela,
bond purchase sparks anger.
It paid about $865,000,000 for two point
$8,000,000,000 worth of bonds.
All right,
so what does this mean?
Well,
it means Goldman Sachs bought Venezuelan
bonds for a third of their value.
In other words,
theoretically the government of
Venezuela is expected to pay back two
point $8,000,000,000 to Goldman Sachs
despite the fact that they only paid
$865 million US dollars for them,
and so now you might be wondering,
well,
why does Venezuela accept this deal?
Well,
the answer is simply because they need
cash or they needed as soon as possible.
Second,
they also know they're never going to
happen
right
now.
You might be wondering,
well,
why did bank is lend them the money?
If they know they're not going to get it
back?
Whereas the business appeal here,
so basically this appeal bias and
interest rates,
I mean,
think about it.
If Venezuela against Goldman Sachs,
10 percent of those two point 8 billion
every year,
and that means the bank will have
covered that investments,
those $865 million dollars in less than
three years,
and after that,
everything is profit.
Now of course,
investors know that Venezuela is going
to default.
The
question here is when are they going to
do it?
So investors are making a high risk that
yet it found a swale.
It keeps paying for at least four years.
Banks will win if they don't,
the banks will lose.
And the truth is,
Nicolas Maduro is the first one
interested in not bankruptcy.
On the one hand,
he needs to keep bankers on his side so
he can pay his repression.
Machinery.
On the other hand,
PDV s,
a Venezuela's state owned oil company
has several properties abroad,
trees and refineries in countries like
Haiti and the Dominican Republic.
If Caracas defaults,
some of those investors might seize
them.
This is white.
For several years,
Venezuela has prioritized that debt
payments over anything else.
Maduro is foreign.
Currency reserves went from more than
$50,
billion dollars to less than 10 billion.
And this explains why a magazine like
Forbes said this about Venezuelan bonds
in 2016
steam.
Venezuela might be the worst country in
Latin America,
but it's bonds look great.
In the middle of 2017,
Donald Trump had to pass a law banning
American banks and hedge funds from
investing in Venezuela.
Nonetheless,
no matter how badly maduro tried,
his economy was weaker than he thought.
Venezuela to restructure foreign debt
default looms as possibility.
Yes,
you had that right.
Goldman Sachs and the rest of those
hedge funds who bought a Venezuelan
bonds at a discount price,
they've lost their best.
Nonetheless.
That is still one investor that is far
from being worried and yes,
of course we're talking about China.
China's puppet as we said at the
beginning,
Venezuela is the country that received
the most Chinese money in Latin America.
This,
unlike the private bankers,
China's government does not buy bonds on
markets.
Instead she drink thing as a personal
meeting with Nicolas Maduro and meeting
where they negotiated a very special
deal alone that is not to be paid back
with money,
but with oil this way.
Beijing makes sure they have an oil
supplier,
no matter what happens,
but all of them.
A second tip,
because this formula,
it's got its drawbacks too.
As you know,
PDVSA is a hyper bureaucratic company
with thousands of workers,
hard by Chavez,
out of pure nepotism.
Oil drilling is harder and harder for
them.
In fact,
they need those dinosaur juice shipments
are arriving pretty late to China,
but despite all of that,
China keeps them loyalty to Venezuela.
That was showing solidarity with the
Venezuelan people because we are
supporting the principals of the United
Nations.
This is what we have to do that.
So now the question becomes,
well,
why?
What does China get from Venezuela now
that they are facing problems with that
while payments?
Well,
the answer lies in the long run.
Just think about it.
Beijing has already lent $50,
billion dollars to crack us.
Now they just need patients and
stability.
Missouri Madeira
needs some years to pay back.
Is that?
Well,
no rush project Mangan waste.
However,
that is something that could risk the
payback of these debts and that is
changing governments.
What would happen if the opposition to
Nicolas Maduro took power?
Would they be willing to meet their
obligations?
Do they use you?
It helps the dictator,
the one who sent them to jail and
probably tortured them.
Sounds like a pretty risky proposition.
Nan's well,
risk is the least favorite word for the
Chinese Communist Party and it explains
things like this
that is really defends purchase of
Chinese right control gear.
After more than 70 deaths in street
protests,
China has already sold over $350,
million dollars worth of weapons to
Madeira so that he can stay in power.
Thanks to things movements.
Caracas is China's biggest ally in the
region.
Basically the Venezuelan government is
to become the puppets of the Chinese
Communist Party.
So well.
What happens?
Well,
maybe China wants to build new
infrastructure in South America so they
can complete that Silk Road project.
While no problem,
I'm in Venezuela.
Diplomats will support them with no
questions asked.
Maybe China wants to have a military
base in the region.
Well,
welcome to Venezuela,
just like that.
They'll get thousands of square miles to
place that Ami as they please.
In other words,
well,
there isn't a better ally than the one
that needs you in order to survive.
Venezuela hopes no country hinders
China's fantastic Silk Road initiative.
Nonetheless,
that instilled dapcep having as much
power as they have.
China might request other kinds of
reforms.
For instance,
if Venezuela that keeps facing problems
with that oil payments,
they might force maduro too for people
at PD vsa and make it more productive.
That could even take over the
exploitation of the old themselves.
Sorry.
The question here is,
can Venezuela become China's colony?
Do you think China is going to seize
Venezuelan oil forever?
Well,
we'd love to know your answer and you
can leave it in the comments section
below and if you want to learn more
about how the Venezuelan crisis started,
check out our other video and don't
forget to visit reconsider media.com,
the podcast that provided the vocals on
this video that are not mine,
and as always,
remember that we published brand new
videos every week,
Monday and Thursday,
hit that subscribe button to not miss
any post,
and if you liked this video,
do give us a thumbs up and as I always
say,
I'll see you in the next video and if
you want to learn more about politics
and hear even more of my lovely voice,
you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com
slash podcast.